heat pick up full court and drop back
into that zone again
Butler's still out Tatum 16th foot chain
is pure Jason Tatum has answered every
run here
it's Butler defended by Brown Scoops it
out blocked by Tatum on the shot by
Vincent and he goes down
that affects everything
Tatum he'll put up a three
he knew there was no way that Vincent
was going to be able to contest that
shot fire and passion there by the 34
year old
Joe Missoula
unch
[Music]
didn't get to hire his own staff but
still 57 wins and he's in the Eastern
Conference Finals and Jason Tatum Reggie
is putting this game away step up and
play at home like they played tonight
it's a Tatum shot off
Jason congratulations on the win how big
is the weight that has been lifted off
of your shoulders uh we're down 3-0
can't we ain't put too much pressure on
ourselves and got
uh try to take it one game at a time uh
we weren't thinking about winning four
in a row tonight we just trying to save
our season and win tonight uh and we did
that shots just weren't following this
series the fourth quarter in particular
was frustrating for you what did you
guys catch and what did you find tonight
and now that you have it what can we
look forward to uh I think you know all
series I think we've been generating
good shots
you know
it's a making mislead sometimes they
just don't go in but tonight you know we
play with Pace purpose we're getting
stopped and we're getting out of
transition you know you see layups and
free throws go in the jump shot to feel
a lot easier see you in Boston
congratulations on the way thank you
they have lost three in a row they have
not lost four in a row in two years and
that will continue winning tonight
keeping the series alive